so this is the last afternoon of the
conference I hope you're enjoying as
much as I am and we the team are now the
game is going to talk us again about
blockchain is an aerospace engineer who
became a data scientist and I don't know
you but I've been hearing about
blockchain lately so I think it's going
to be like the next hype so I'm really
excited
so VM this is all yours TV my aroma a
run of applause thanks to the
introduction it's I think that there's
only one thing that has received more
hype lately than neural networks that is
blockchain I mean the hive that this has
in the corporate and financial world
Dwarfs the one of machine learning and
it's sad because what happens is that
it's something that's quite easy
understandable at least the ups and
downs that this technology has it's
quite easy to understand so I'm here to
fix that my this conference this thought
will be successfully after that you more
or less have an intuition of what are
the good things and the bad things that
blockchain distributed Ledger's which is
the kind of general technology that you
I mean how you name on a more general
way this technology and smart contracts
work mandatory is lied about me you
probably seen that three times so I'm
sorry again my Twitter and I don't with
so much we're hiring no one has come to
me yet say what kind of profile you want
at least so you're not that interested I
don't know we're a fine company I think
and here's all the talk materials and
don't information you need this
blockchain in distributed Ledger's
it has a nice kind of white paper it's
not very long but I think that if you
like this talk you should read it it's
more or less the content of this talk
this but this is a good way to remind
so blockchain who has ever heard of
Bitcoin good who hears have heard of
blockchain good who here has ever heard
of distributed pledges all of you should
have raised the hand because a
distributed led blockchain is a
distributed ledger okay but first of all
what is a ledger this is a ledger okay
it is a table it can be in paper it can
be a database it can be in whatever
format a ledger is a series of ordered
records no matter what they contain the
only thing is that they are ordered and
they cannot keep consensus between
several peers on what is the status of
all the collective in this case that is
a sense it keeps a record of all the
people who's registered in the sensor so
that the people that has a right to vote
but you may think that this is quite
also lettuce has been you we've been
using lettuce for quite a long time well
it seems that we've been using letters
for several thousand years so that's
definitely not a new technology letters
are the bread and butter of accounting
registration auditing let us are the way
in which mankind makes business
everything that is not in a ledger this
doesn't exist because we cannot find an
agreement on that
so how let us have worked for 7,000
years and I'm not exaggerating
it's about 7,000 years we've been doing
business the same way it's very simple
you have an authority that it is either
imposed to you by further authority a
government super national institution
and they say okay this institution will
hold the data of the ledger it can be
again someone that has some power or the
several members of the community or
community
a group of whatever agree who has to
hold the data the important thing of the
leaders is that he who holds the data
also has the liability and
responsibility to keep that data safe
and not tampering with it not using it
in his own interest and that is
important and usually for this liability
he charges some money it's a service if
I keep a ledger of I don't know the
transactions that several banks do
between them I can charge what I can
charge them for that storing that
information because if my system just
breaks down or I accidentally delete
some of those information those banks
can sue me
and then I have a problem so it's a kind
of mutual economical agreement but the
important thing is that no matter how
money you charge for keeping that ledger
that central authority gets how much
money it gets to keep that ledger the
whole thing is based on trust even in
Mesopotamia the guy that kept that thing
was trusted by the people who asked to
put that annotation on that piece of
clay okay that is important and one half
what happened when one of those Ledger's
had some issues
it burned or the institution collapsed
very easy all the members of the group
that use that ledger went to different
institution that kept the information on
a similar way now we use databases but
it's very similar okay but what happened
in 2008 a global financial meltdown I
think that you all remember that and
what means what does a global financial
meltdown mean there's a crisis on trust
banks started selling the each other
toxic assets people love the money there
was a huge crisis on trust
but this doesn't mean that the important
thing the compute difference between the
last global financial crisis and all the
financial crisis that ever happened
before
was that that for the first time in
history they could choose and this is
something completely known that is it's
what blocks an end Bitcoin brought to
the game for the first time they didn't
need a central authority to hold the
data for the first time and this is
important
blockchain was the first case in which
you could hold a market in a completely
distributed manner and you should not
trust a central authority it was for the
first time that the data that ledger was
not owned by anyone and this anyone
couldn't apply the authority on that
data the data was everyone's okay what
is the mark on track I don't know why
every time that someone talks about to
mark on deck they put pictures like that
the problem I have is that every time
that I see two persons holding hands I
think about this but anyways what is
this mark on track and this is curious
because people think nowadays that smart
contracts and distributed Ledger's are a
very related thing and they're not
they're completely separate concepts and
that's curious how we hype how building
a discourse changed in people's
perceptions it's not that if you go to
the Wikipedia and you pick the
definition of smart contract it just
sets just as it is a computer program
that allows or facilitates the
negotiation between two parts worse big
kinder if the definition doesn't need a
distributed ledger at all doesn't says
anything on how you must store the data
of that agreement so why people thinks
that a distributed contract has to go
with blockchain
I mean their answer to that is no I mean
there's a lot of people that it has
build this discourse but that's not true
again if you have a distributed contract
you need to store that in a database
okay and we've seen that it is good to
have this database distribute it okay
but what people don't tell you and this
is something that's very important when
you design this kind of a smart
contracts on distributed ledger is the
cost you pay for keeping that data
distributed okay so we have two models
it's important to keep that in mind you
have two models the model that has been
working for 7,000 years which is keeping
that information centralized and one
owner keeps that data safe or go into
distributed ledger okay and we can
understand distributed Ledger's and the
type in the price we have to pay for
going to a sent decentralized model with
very easy theory on computer science and
this is the basic theory and it is quite
basic
I will see that allows you to understand
the ups and downs of going from a
centralized model to distributed model
and I can tell and I I can tell you you
will see that in a moment it has a huge
payoff it's not free and why is that
what from what what the costs come who
knows about the cap theorem I think that
the most people that just raise the hand
are also computer scientists probably or
have worked with distributed systems
that is a theorem it's not the gap
theory it's the cap theorem it means
that it has been proven what that
theorem says is that if you want to
store data in parallel in a distributed
system you have three possible promises
one is that that the data will be in a
consistent way it means that the last
state
we'll be available that means
consistency is that all the notes are
able to see the same data it will means
availability means that the data will be
available immediately so see I carry a
distributed database and availability it
means that it will never answer an error
or I don't know or wait no no it will
mean that I can access the data
immediately
and finally partition tolerant that
means it has a more complicated
complicated definition a more complex
definition but it basically means
parallel so if you want to be
distributed you have this there's no
other way so you can't you have to
choose between one of those two and
which one you need availability or
consistency you're building the ledger
to this you need this too and this is
the one hanging what does availability
means availability means latency okay if
you put data in parallel and you want to
build a distributed ledger to hold
contracts you will have latency you will
have to wait for that contract to be
signed somehow okay but how much latency
and that is important you know now that
you have some latency but how much okay
I said first concept capturing the
second concept who knows about the
Byzantine agreement problem one two
three four there's one problem it was
stated by Leslie Lamport like 20 years
ago and now in sensitive Python
conference I instead of calling it the
Byzantine generals problem I will call
it the French castle problem okay okay
imagine that you have serious of
generals and they're trying to invade a
Byzantine city sorry you're part of the
Ottoman ottoman I'm sorry you want to
invade an ottoman city and you're a set
of Byzantine generals
and they're camped around the city and
they know that K they can win that
battle if they agree and how to attack
or retreat okay the only requirement for
them to be victorious is that whatever
the strategy is either attack or to
retreat all of them must apply exactly
the same exact theory is if only one of
them applies a different strategy they
lose okay so if you think about that
it's okay I have many generals and
they've must do the same and it seems
easy okay in the most general form it is
proven that this problem has no solution
because at first you can think okay just
I have one general traitor
one general is a traitor okay just cheat
him I will attack I just tell him that
we will retreat he will apply the
inverse strategy and I went but what
happens if one of them is deaf one of
them is sick in the tent two of them are
traitors three of them are stupid you
lose but that's important upset kind of
two possible cases you have one general
with a traitor or you have a huge
problem for consistency again remember
the cap theory
consistency is what you want okay and
I've said okay now I have a problem of
latency of availability
how much latency do I have and this is
important concept that Byzantine
agreement provides the harder the
Byzantine agreement is the mo latency I
will have if I'm trying to solve an easy
Byzantine agreement problem which is
that I have a faulty network then I will
be able to find a consensus very rapidly
but if all the all the people who's
using the network is trying to cheat me
then finding consensus on which data
have store I had to store it will be
very hard okay so the harder the
consensus the mole agency I have because
I need more time to reach a consensus
between all the pairs so I think that we
have easy concepts consensus and I want
to store information in parallel in a
consistent way blockchain is an example
of that blonde blockchain has a
Byzantine agreement problem which is
double spending okay what is double
spending very easy
I hold my blog thing and I try to teach
someone to people to spend the same
exactly exact same block tank in two
different transactions and I hope that
these two people will never look at the
same time if Phi and Ray transferred
those blockades so sorry those bitcoins
okay so with actual cash the only way I
can I have to do that is to falsify the
bill with a bank that's impossible
basically because it's a centralized
ledger a bank has a centralized ledger
and knows exactly with which currency I
spent what it happens is that solving
this problem the one of double spending
is particularly hard it's one of the
hardest Byzantine Agreement problems
that there are and the clearest thing is
that that thing was not solved until
2008 when Blockson was designed the
boxing protocol was designed and bitcoin
was released that was a revolution for
first time we had a protocol system that
allowed to make useful by solving the
particularly hard Byzantine agreement
problem and it solved this way imagine
that I have Alice and Bob and Alice
doesn't trust him Bob sorry Alice owes
money to Bob but Bob doesn't trust Alice
at all
says she will try to cheat she will try
to pretend that she's sending the money
but she will try not to do it actually
so in the blockchain protocol what they
do is Alice will not actually do the
transaction anywhere he will pick the
transaction with that information like
transfer that much blockchain sorry that
much Bitcoin to Bob and instead of
sending it to Bob you will send it to a
series of - and this transaction will be
ledger will be ordered in a block okay
and those - one of them by mere luck
that's the point of the algorithm just
one of them will make something called
the proof of work
which is a very hard computation and
from the millions and millions of now
there are probably millions of - one of
them will solve this problem in it will
say to the rest of the network
these transactions that were in my vlog
the one I was mining this trance actions
are now part of the larger whatever our
Hardware transactions I received now
third information that everyone must
trust again Alice cannot manipulate
those - she can only send the
transaction so the only thing that bob
has to do is to wait from some minor to
say which transactions are the good ones
and as soon as they get added to the
blockchain both can see that Alice has
made the transcripts and that's it
doesn't that sound complex for
transferring money I mean how do you
transfer money you go to your bank
you tell your bank transferred that
money to this account and done okay this
is because the fact of having people
trying to cheat this all the time is a
requirement for such a complicated
agreement
okay so what are the costs of a
particularly hard agreement protocol or
consensus protocol okay
each block is only one megabyte which is
very small one megabyte okay one block
is mined every 10 minutes so you have a
database that has a bandwidth of one
megabyte for every 10 minutes does that
sound a lot that doesn't sound a lot it
means that the whole Bitcoin and
blockchain are is a database that allows
for transaction per second does that
sound a lot no by the way the blockchain
is already finding the maximum so there
they're just reaching the peak bandwidth
look at that look at the bank Alice
wants to transfer money Bob Alice trust
in her bank that trusts Bob Bank the
trust Bob transferred on but what is the
price we pay here trust and that is the
next idea I want to put here in your
minds not trusting in the systems is
what makes things complicated so every
system that uses Ledger's or twice the
stores information it gets much
simplified by trusting in the people
that has to hold the data so we go back
to smart contracts smart contracts again
they're just a way of finding agreement
between supports what happens if one
part doesn't trust the other one it has
to pay a price that's it this is no
other way but if there's some common
trust between those two party they can
store information in a different way and
that we can make those transactions more
efficient and what happens is that you
look there are many platforms for smart
contracts right now
maybe some of them bring the bell to you
once called aetherium which is a kind of
relative of blockchain we have you have
either ledger and then you have other
protocols that are also used for
financial transactions like people but
if you look at the platforms that are
general platforms for smart contracts
they all look the same you look you go
to I Piper ledger you read the white
papers you go to aetherium you read the
white papers and what is the smart
contract really in those platforms a
smart contract is just a series of
attributes a is equal to 1 B is equal to
C is equal to a list of strings and then
methods that change the value of those
attributes this is a class in smart
contract platforms a smart contract is a
class you have attributes and you have
methods that change those attributes
that's it
it's as simple as it sounds where's all
the complication in storing that in a
way the no trust is required but in a
class you trust in the Python
interpreter so you just run Python it's
ok
and what did I do since the whole smart
contract ecosystem is getting very very
complicated just the curse of the
infrastructure of the possibility of not
needing trust I just did the complete
opposite I implemented one smart
contract platform that is PI ledger that
just stores information in a database
that's it you can use it to play with
smart contracts to see if they are
powerful if they work for you so you can
experiment and again what does this mark
what is a smart contract smart contract
is a class
so demo time
okay I have in this virtual environment
at pilot or install and it has a server
which is a Python file that serves a
very simple smart contract which is a
kind of stupid digital currency and this
is this more contract so it's all that
it is it is a class digital currency
that inherits from simple contract oh by
the way does everyone see that look at
this what's this type annotations I
found the use case for type annotations
but see I mean that's a class you have
account which is a class attribute
because basically smart contracts
technically speaking smart contracts can
be Singleton's so you have add account
increment transfer balance things that
look like a currency a currency system
and I then I just run it run digital
currency that's it in the class you're
on a class ok this is how hard is to
make a smart contract run say I will run
o event loop yes it has a sink I own and
Anna run a shell and I will connect to
clients to this contract
okay and very briefly I just connected
it this locks that I open a WebSocket
connections is because the client and
the server connected by a WebSocket and
I only think they say I don't know
contracts so digital currency what is
the I 500 I have ad account balance
transfer increment
and what is my balance to you oh by the
way this is server based so i can do
exactly the same thing okay sorry
digital currency valence key Michael Oh
a come not found it's because oh yeah
that's because I I forgot to sync it
with a declaration but it's okay the
thing here is that it's the demo gods
never allow you to make it a successful
demo so it's okay okay oh yeah
oops it doesn't have red line support
well balance is zero again I can
broadcast into the other cell hello so
it is true smart contract platforms the
only thing is that you don't pay the
price of having that in a huge
infrastructure of course that's not for
everyone but the problem I had when I
try to explain smart contracts to anyone
is that okay how do I play with smart
contracts and the answers that people
just can't so now with this you can at
least play with them which is a nice
thing oh by the way it's still rough
around the edges I've just changed
implementation I moved from tornado to
Autobahn because I wanted to have
WebSockets to have nice things like
broadcasting so it's not perfect but I
think that's good enough so you can play
that about you can play with that so
that's all I have
[Applause]
VM it was very interesting if you have
any questions so like a we would be
happy to listen
hello thanks for the talk and why not
test in the smart contrast in a test net
you know in a test net you know do too I
tell you every everyone has that isn't
it and if it is difficult to get some
coins for the test net you can forge
your own Genesis block and besides your
own separate private kaznia but that is
the cost if you that is I thought about
that building a test net and whatever it
happened is that how can you build a
test how you let a functional consultant
in a consulting company to build a test
net hold it in the systems and all that
thing and I face the same difficulty and
I realized that I just tested it it was
like a crazy gas can I develop something
in four days which is the same time it
takes me to understand how to build and
run a test net can I build a platform
for small contract on the same time and
the answer was yes it's just trial and
error and just this was faster and when
things for the for the doc it was
amazing have you ever tried the solidity
online it'll you can put this my
contract and he has like a way that you
can check it you can test it and it's
not Python YZ space in Java but easily
no no III aetherium what I mean is that
if urine is great I ask this is not a
criticism on current small contract
platforms but the thing is that I wanted
something that I can have up and running
prototyping in my life top if I'm not
connected and I want to go with my
laptop and lower someone to test it and
I want something easier much easier
I mean someone tells me to me it Hyrum
is
I will say it's not easy enough for me
that is my general it's not a criticism
aetherium is a wonderful piece of
project it solves many things it is an
amazing technology but I want something
simple that is my contribution okay and
another question is have you ever tried
the Python library for web 3 is the
Epperson library for a web tree today
happy for working with you cerium I know
I opened it and I looked at it I didn't
plan to use it because I already have a
knowledge about gas and all the command
lines for a cerium and I the thing is
that once I saw that I just jumped in
trying to develop something questions
and do mention that the bandwidth of
Bitcoin is as one man I met alight every
10 minutes on average but there are some
projects to elevate us for example the
language network in which meet with
meager payment channels do anything you
can have thousands of transactions a
bill to our transactions per real
transaction so do you think we need to
worry about the language program or yes
everyone's worrying about the bandwidth
problem because the problem is that how
again it's about consensus you get to a
sub payment platform then which one then
you have 30 different platforms that
rely on blockchain for sub transactions
the the genesis blocks for Experian
private networks are also stored in the
blockchain and the problem is again
agreement the nice thing about the
blockchain is that for the first time
people agreed on something that was
distributed it has nothing to do valve
technology this is social and they think
what's happening now is that people is
designing protocols what if it met those
protocols
be successful are the ones is now based
on the block tank like ripple ripple is
a great protocol and it probably will
make a lot of money because they
understood that maybe they have to use a
different kind of agreement protocol
what I mean is that this is not settled
there are a lot of things and who knows
where the market market will go but
smart contracts will be there and I just
needed something to test them any I am
thinking to talk I'll just wondering do
you see so you mentioned that in your
case you built by legitimate simple and
you or you assume trust in many
occasions do you see applications for
this type of smart cluttering way the
simple smart contracts that are not
distributed what I call the ledges yeah
yes I do probably there will not be
based on pilot Oh
because it's a toy but I think that they
have up just this has nothing to do with
programming okay banks base their
business on trust I'm sure that they
will base if some Bank kind of create a
platform for smart contracts they will
try them too they will try that you
trust them so at the end the model they
will try to impose is one in which they
store all the data so if some Authority
asks you to use a smart contract it will
be more similar to this than to the
blockchain thank you
so in I was wondering also don't you
have to trust then in there miners in
the in the blockchain model because
there are also some there is any
possibility that the miners do something
have you ever heard about the Dow crisis
no the Dow the the creators of aetherium
created a platform for a huge a smart
contract that was a platform to trade
services what happened is that someone
found the vulnerability vulnerability
not in aetherium but in the
implementation of Dow because
experiments just a platform for smart
contracts then you have to do the
contract and it has to be correct has to
be the right properties has to be the
right authentications just a platform
then you may get the contract wrong a
researcher found that the dow had a buck
and he could drain money without trading
anything so he I think that he got a
worth were worth $40,000 worth of things
or four million dollars worth of things
without trading anything and what
happened was that since the Dow was so
in infant in its infancy they branched
the blockchain which is goes it goes
against the ethics of blockchain so you
manipulated the blockchain because you
did something wrong why should I trust
you now
you own the blockchain and you decided
to manipulate it because you did
something wrong no according to the
blockchain that's something that's
written forever you just can go pick the
eraser and just remove that even in
distributed letters you have trust
issues but the thing is that those trust
issues are not asked obvious as this guy
has the data thank you
two more questions so it's your head and
also if for example if the mining nodes
are competing in the blockchain
I mean if now if in this moment we want
to become a miner is impossible because
you need a computing engine that is not
possible
so blockchain now is is controlled by
mining pools so if someone built a
supercomputer mining pool is going to to
win all the competition so at the end is
going to become the controller of the
oscillator if that in fact happened one
of the mining pools once got 51% of the
mining power and what happened is that
there was an agreement again agreement
is about trust and consensus there was
an agreement so that pool removed - so
it went back to the 40% of the mining
power so again the fact that you store
that in a blockchain doesn't remove all
the issues it still has issues it's just
that at least it's distributed but of
course it still has issues what do you
say it has a very happened do you think
is an issue for the news private
blockchains that is going to appear in
the future that yeah I mean there will
be private blockchains there will be all
legal poly block chains and with some
banks or some institutions decide to
make a blocking only for them for things
that are in for for which they don't
even trust each other and there will be
smart contracts with centralized
ventures I think that there will be a
whole family of smart contracts running
them different storage strategies that
is my guess I may be one okay so thank
you once again game for me was really
lighting it's giving another applause
[Applause]